I know I haven't always gonna write but
as far as this goes there really was no
other option
Prince Harry speaking out for the first
time since news broke that he and Megan
Merkel will exit the royal family what I
want to make clear is we're not walking
away and we certainly aren't walking
away from you the 35 year old chose to
address the elephant in the room at a
dinner for supporters of his charities
sent to ballet in London on Sunday our
heart was to continue serving the Queen
the Commonwealth and my military
associations but without public funding
unfortunately that wasn't possible I've
accepted this knowing that it doesn't
change who I am or how committed I am
but I hope that helps you understand
what did it come to that I would step my
family back from all I have ever known
just take us to take a step forward into
what I hope can be a more peaceful life
I was born into this life and it is a
great honor to serve my country and the
Queen Harry went on to thank a crowd we
are taking a leap of faith so thank you
for giving me the courage to take this
next step he even threw in this adorable
reference to his eight month old son it
has also been a privilege to meet so
many of you and to feel your excitement
for our son watching who Harry sir marks
come one day after Queen Elizabeth
announced they'd reached a decision
regarding he and wife Megan markle's
future I always protect my family I know
I have a family to protect as our
favorite ginger spelled out this means
no more official duties including
Harry's official military appointments
and no more public funds
what's more Harry and Megan will lose
their royal titles so rather than going
by his and her Royal Highness they will
simply go by Harry Duke of Sussex and
Megan Duchess of Sussex not many people
have asked if I'm okay but it's
it's a very real thing to be going
through behind the scenes in her
statement the Queen acknowledged the
challenges Megan and Harry have
experienced as a result of intense
scrutiny over the last two years adding
that they will always be much-loved
members of my family and that she
supports their wish for a more
independent life Frogmore cottage will
remain Megan Harry and Archie's official
UK residents as they split time between
England and Canada and according to the
palace the couple will repay the money
they use to refurbish it they'll also
continue to maintain their private
patronage is like Harry's beloved
Invictus we need to do is focus focus on
being real and focus on being the people
that we are and standing up for what we
believe in while many are applauding
Megan in Harry's royal exit which goes
into effect this spring the Duchess is
estranged father Thomas Merkel is
slimming their decision they're
destroying it they're keeping and
they're making it shabby they're turning
it into a Walmart with a crown on it
that's Tom is speaking out in a new clip
from the upcoming Channel five
documentary obtained by Sky News it's
disappointing because she actually got
every girl's dream to become a princess
and now she's tossing that away for it
looks like she's tossing away for money
Thomas goes on to say that he can't see
making her Harry reaching out to him
especially now after his latest comments
adding that he thinks they're both
turning into lost souls